here with reaction House Intelligence
Committee chairman Devin Nunez
congressman good to see you thank you
for being with us great to be back I am
a bit stunned at the ship memo and I
think I guess there's a reason that many
in the liberal media aren't covering it
because it corroborates so much of what
you said the steel dossier as the
Grassley grand memo says was the bulk of
the information that that phony
unverified Russian Clinton bought and
paid for Russian da say that was the
bulk of the FISA warrant that's now on
the record correct
yeah that that is the case and not only
that it is basically the bulk of the
entire investigation
it's what the Democrats have used over
and over again
they've always went back to Carter page
it wasn't until a couple weeks ago that
they started to distance himself from
the dossier which was their information
that they paid for all right and they
what's so important to me is so Hillary
if she's bought and paid for her in the
DNC then it's used as the basis for a
FISA warrant but here's what's not
addressed by Adam Schiff and he loves
television I mean he's literally
auditioning daily to be an MSNBC
contributor but the most glaring thing
to me is it never mentions in his memo
at all Clinton or the DNC just like it
was never told to the FISA judge
outright
that's that's our biggest that's our
biggest problem from the beginning and
remember this was only about FISA abuse
phase one of our investigation was to
say look FISA abuse occurred and the
reason that we wanted the Democratic
memo out if you if recall over two weeks
ago as soon as as soon as that wit was
sent over to the White House we're like
hey we wanted out the White House came
back the FBI and DOJ said hey make the
changes and get it back out well then
what you had is this supposed cover-up
they were blaming the president saying
the president wasn't getting this out
that was the farthest thing from the
truth they could have gotten this out
two weeks ago they could have made the
redactions the FBI and DOJ wanted and
they could have gotten this out and we
wanted it out for precisely the reasons
that that you're mentioning tonight and
the DOJ and the FBI never verified the
Clinton bought and paid for Dasia
although
they knew it was political in nature
that she had paid for it they never did
their own verification well I think
that's what's even more telling about
the Democratic memo that we like is that
they're actually saying they actually
say in their in the footnote and they
give you the verbatim they go out of
their way to actually say how how this
was used how it was political but then
they don't say specifically who paid for
it which which we can and we just can't
have we just can't have a FISA Court we
can't have our intelligence agencies and
our intelligence capabilities used to
target one political party against
another and that's what happened here it
isn't that lying below mission sir well
I'm not an expert on that Sean but but
clearly the way we see it it was a lot
more complicated to put what they put
into into what the to put what the FBI
and DOJ presented to the FISA Court then
it would have been just to say look here
here judge this is who paid for it I
guess the next thing I want to know is
so we've had allegation at the
allegation hour after allegation Trump
Russia collusion is there any evidence
to date of any Trump Russia collusion of
any kind that you or anybody on your
committee or anybody in the FBI or
Department of Justice or Robert Muller's
investigation has come up with that you
have seen not that I've seen and the
only collusion that I continue to say
that I have seen and we have proof of is
that the Democrats hired a British agent
foreign British agent who went to
suppose it Russians to get dirt on the
Trump campaign I mean that is it is
collusion it's clear collusion and
nobody's investigating it and nobody's
talking about it our crimes in your view
committed here in terms of the FISA
application the role of high-ranking not
rank-and-file high-ranking FBI DOJ
intelligence people and what does it say
about this whole year plus that this
country has been consumed with an
investigation that apparently has no
evidence whatsoever should it go away
well look I think you have there's a
variety of crimes that you'd have to
look at you have conspiracy would be the
largest it's also the hardest to prove
you have a line in misleading Congress
you have the court that could actually
do something if they feel like they were
lied to but the bigger problem here I
think over all of this just for the
justifies abuse specifically is I think
the American public reject the idea that
you can use a secret court take
political dirt from one party and use it
against another I think all Americans
can agree with that then in glen simpson
also admit in testimony that in fact he
never corroborated he never verified and
at times i believe it might have been
the senate maybe not your committee but
i believe he also admitted that they had
coordinated in terms of media outreach
to get out information that was never
verified that was clinton bought and
paid for that was connected to russia
well look you have to assume i mean you
know that glenn simpson and steele were
meeting with numerous reporters and
maybe this is why when i say the media
is dead maybe they're embarrassed right
because so many of them were briefed
maybe they can't actually write about it
because the emperor would have no
clothes right it would be the height of
hypocrisy if some of these reporters
would come out and say well yeah we were
actually briefed on this dossier way
back when and you know now knowing that
it's totally false and and totally
disproven so let's salacious and
unverified let me ask you this last
question you said this is phase one at
another point in an interview that we
did together you talked about at least
four other phases can you outline what
else is coming and and the specific
areas of interest that you have in terms
of investigations well the the the area
that we're focusing on right now is the
state department if you look at the
questionnaire that we've sent out so we
have a questionnaire that went out to
current and former member senior members
at the highest levels of government
we're asking them very simple questions
about the dossier when they knew about
it who they told when they knew the
democrats have paid for it that
questionnaire is due this Friday did you
find Susan Rice's note to self on the
final day of the Obama administration
odd well I would say it it is a another
example of a long string
of actions by Susan Rice that I think
are odd
does it scare you that an unverified
political bought and paid for document
full of Russian lies with all the talk
about Russia collusion could make its
way to a FISA Court that the FISA judge
is not informed about its origins and
that it becomes the basis to spy on an
opposition party during in the lead-up
to an election that's giving you as much
as it does me well Sean let me tell you
what scares me more than that
it's that the party who did that okay
meaning the Democrats in the in the
House and the Senate
whose party did this that they're
actually in if you read the Democratic
memo closely they actually say that
that's okay that's scary that to me is
is is really bad it's not oversight and
I think it brings up many questions
about when did they actually know about
this dossier when did they know it was
actually their own dossier that they use
to drum up an investigation on on
Republicans all right congressman thank
you keep up the good work we need the
truth the American people deserve it
when we come